well that gives me a perfect segue
considering
more paper folding so i'm going to talk
about uh paper folding to the moon
i have to be honest with you it's not my
idea right to those of you who know me i
am big on procrastinating and as a
result of procrastination i came across
this ted talk by adrian
panzer and
he was talking about paper folding and
how you know i'll go through it i'll go
through it right
so what i want you to get out of this is
what i did with this particular tedx
talk instead of just taking what i've
got
take the idea away from it and then turn
it into something that will work with
your class
okay scaffold it however you want
structure it however you want something
that your kids are going to really get
into
i have one goal for my students and that
is to move them away from getting just
the answer i hate it my kids tell me
just give me the answer tell me how to
do it right one of the critically
to think critically i wanted to work
together and i wanted to come up want
them to come up with creative ways of
getting to the solution to the problem
that i'm about to pose
and the most important thing
is to get them to communicate
and that is not just verbally
communicating to each other but writing
things down on the page mathematically
and using words and i'm finding that
lots of kids are afraid to use words in
maths to explain themselves i'm always
trying to get them to use words more
often
so
here's some preamble for the problem
suppose that you can fold a piece of
paper many many times over and over
again and you'll get the smart kids in
class and go oh sir but
miss bus myth busters have proven this
you know otherwise
just ignore them
and suppose you have a piece of paper of
infinite size so basically when you fold
it over and over again the piece of
paper doesn't get smaller you know
the question is how many folds would it
take for you to create something that's
thick enough to reach the moon
so
i started with
getting them to do a bit of estimation
okay and it's surprising to hear what
the kids have to say about it lots of
kids went for 100 folds or more because
they haven't really studied exponential
growth
right
so obviously obvious things to do is
looking at thickness of paper and stuff
like that
i won't go through the concepts but you
can really study you know the the
concepts of math talking about measuring
devices limited reading error and
measurement and so on and so on
uh i'm sure the presentation will be
made
available to you through judy
and other things like that you can talk
about significant figures looking at
units
uh
measurements with very large units
and stuff like that and
it has a very nice solution
which is why i really like the problem
look i didn't go i didn't go through the
slides in detail but
when you get a chance go through the
slides the max is there